hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series with the goal of trying
to learn from people who have done more
than us and hopefully some of our magic
pixie dust rubs off on us to help us
achieve more change our mindsets and
achieve our goals so today we're going
to learn from Les Brown on motivation
clip number 10 is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to know which one you
guys like the best I do a lot of
training for many corporations and I
conduct sales seminars and I've heard
all kind of guys doing techniques and
training people techniques of how to
close sales and how to work within and
begin to control the sale and how to ask
for the clothes let me share something
with you you can learn all the
techniques in the world if you don't
believe in yourself
it won't happen for you I learned all of
it so that's why I do a training called
focus on the seller you've got to focus
on you and as you convince you as you
sell yourself every day every day every
day you will begin to see a difference
in the things that you're doing selling
yourself on your ability to perform a
job to achieve a certain objective
telling yourself every day here I go
again and I've got what it takes this is
my day and nothing out here is going to
stop me there are a lot of people who
are biting their fingers in fear that
they might lose their jobs but there are
few people who have decided within
themselves I'm going to make it some
people aren't waiting to be cut some
people are moving on their own because
they feel within themselves I've got
what it takes to make it they're not
afraid about tomorrow because of how
they see themselves because of what they
feel that they deserve because of what
they feel that they can create for
themselves because these people have
decided as they look at the future as
they look at themselves there's a way
where there's a will there's a way for
me to begin to create a way out of no
way
and when you have that kind of
consciousness when you have that kind of
spirit nothing can stop you
nothing what would your life be like as
you look toward the future if you
decided I'm not going to allow my fears
to stop me what would your life be like
what would your future be like if you
decided to to want that which you desire
so strongly that it prepares you past
your fears that you experienced a fear
as the one book says feel the fear and
do it anyway what would your life be
like and I'm saying to you that all of
us who have been entombed by fear have a
capacity to resurrect ourselves and to
resurrect our dreams most people are not
accumulating wealth most people are
living in poverty most people are living
far below their potential not because
they don't have the capacity not because
they have not been given authority and
dominion over everything on the face of
the earth but most people are living
like they're living because of the fact
that they don't believe they can have
anymore than what they now have and the
book called a mis-education of the negro
dr. cottagey Woodson says if you can
determine what a man shall think you
never have to couldn't discern yourself
with what he will do if you can make a
man feel in
you never have to compel into secret in
furious status well he will seek it
himself
and if you can make a man feel justly an
outcast you never have to order him to
go to the back door he'll go without
being told and if there's no door his
very nature will demand why that's why
scripture reminds us be not conformed to
this world but be transformed by the
renewing of your mind so every day you
have to sell yourself and get out of
your mind those old thoughts that old
belief system every day you've got to
sell yourself on that it's possible that
you got to put a new mind in you you got
to get out of your mind you got to begin
to restructure your thinking every day
you've got to begin to recondition your
mind see many of us go through life
making choices thinking it's our choices
and it's not dr. Howard Thurman one of
the mentors of dr. Martin Luther King
jr. and Albert Schweitzer and Mahatma
Gandhi it was a very brilliant writer he
wrote some things that really grabs me
he he wrote deep is to hunger the voice
of the genuine the centering moment
during the time after receiving 238
radiation seed implants I was reflecting
on his words and and these words kept me
up that night he said the ideal
situation for a man a woman to die is to
have family members praying with them as
they cross over he said but imagine if
you will being on your deathbed and
standing around your bed the ghost of
the dreams the ideas the abilities the
talents given to you by life and that
you for whatever reason you never went
after that dream you never acted on
those ideas you never use those talents
you never use those gifts and there they
are standing around your bed looking at
you with large angry eyes saying we came
to you and only you
could have given us life and now we must
die with you forever and the question is
if you die today
what dreams what ideas what talents what
books what music what leadership what
voice will die with you
mouths Monroe break or Aten speaker said
the wealthiest place in the planet it's
not in a 40s where there's oil in the
ground it's not in South Africa whether
diamond lands is that the wealthiest
place on the planet is the cemetery but
you there you'll find greatness if we've
never seen there you find talent in
genius and potential never actualize
perhaps that's why Henry David Thoreau
wrote the words all God to reach the
point of death only to realize that
you've never lived maybe that's why some
unknown writer wrote the words what if
you live your whole life only to
discover that it was wrong that it was
wrong that you were chosen to do
something else and you didn't do it
I'm saying this is the time more than
ever that you want to begin to inoculate
yourself with positive words coming to
conventions showing up on meetings being
on the calls to make yourself
unstoppable to get out of your mind the
polluting negative thoughts that's
causing most people to go through life
being stuck because they are volunteer
victims somebody said that many people
died aged 25 and don't get buried until
there are 65 because they got so much
garbage in their minds you are here
because you've got a clear vision of
what you want and where you're going
give yourselves a round of applause
come on putting energy level of yes yes
you want more you want more you're
different you're different than
everybody else don't worry if they don't
get it don't try and convince people to
do this business a person convinced
against their will is of the same
opinion still you are not like everybody
else you can walk outside and find
pigeons but if you're looking for Eagles
it's gonna take you a minute you are
different
it's lonely at the top how many of you
know it's lonely at the top raise your
hands it's lonely at the top but you eat
better that's what I'm talking about
you're different
one great entrepreneur said I choose not
to be a common man it's my right to be
uncommon if I can I'll seek opportunity
not security I do not wish to be a kept
citizen humbled and dull by having the
state look after me I want to take the
calculated risk to dream and to bill to
fail and to succeed I refuse them there
from hand to mouth I prefer the
challenges of life to the guaranteed
existence the thrill of fulfillment to
the still calm of utopia I will never
cower before him master nor been to any
threat it's my heritage to stand erect
proud and unafraid the face to whirl
boldly and say this I have done you
showed up because you're building a
business that you can stand and say I
did this I did this this is
my dream give yourselves a round of
applause yes yes the other thing is take
full responsibility for your life except
where you are and the responsibility
that you're going to take yourself where
you want to go so once that we have two
primary choices in life we can either
accept conditions as they exist or we
can take the responsibility to change
them see a lot of people want to exempt
themselves from taking responsibility
all they want to do is talk about the
problem every time you see them they'll
tell you their story over and over and
over and over again no no you want to
take responsibility for your life
I got me here I can get me out of this
and I'm getting out I'm not going to be
a volunteer victim George Bernard Shaw
said there are two kinds of people in
life you know he said those that make
things happen those that watch things
happen and those that don't know what
happened
and he said the people to get alone in
this life look around for the
circumstances that they want and if they
can't find them they may come they
creator so part of beginning to get
unstuck you've got to decide that the
behavior pattern that you have adopted
doesn't work for you you've got to
change your strategies and changing your
strategy means reinventing your life
recreating you and you have the power to
do that you can decide that you're going
to change that you're not going to be a
wimp
you can decide that you're going to
stand up to life
you can decide that I'm going to live
each day as if it were my last you can
you have the power to make that decision
you can decide I'm going to work on
myself and develop myself I'm going to
empower me and all of these things that
are happening to me right now they're
just temporary inconveniences they're
not stronger than I am
I'm in charge here see when you are not
filling your life with the things that
you are capable of doing so we all have
some stuff that we've been given and I
don't think that it's optional for us to
sit on what we have see if you're
sitting on what you have what you've
been given I think everybody has been
given something to bring to the planet
that only you can do that only you can
perform that only you can initiate that
activity and if you don't do that if
you're not filling in your life with
your life work or your mission then
there are gaps in your life and what we
do when we're not living out our true
identity we begin to fill the gaps we
fill the holes with garbage alcohol
drugs worry self-destructive behavior so
when you begin to look at your life and
you know that that you're not doing what
you can do because you have allowed
yourself to be held captive by your
fears
now when you don't have a true
appreciation and acceptance for who you
are and you allow yourself to be
immobilized by fear
happens in the processes that you begin
to amuse yourself you begin to sabotage
your life you begin to sabotage your
dreams you begin to unconsciously work
against yourself you become your own
worst enemy so what do you do about that
well you you begin to realize that your
dream and your gifts have so much
meaning and so much value for you till
your hunger for them will begin to push
you past the fear your hunger to have
them will give you a special drive as
you work on yourself as you begin to
acknowledge your true identity the true
power that you have the true capacity
you have to bring about change the
miracle-working power that you have
within yourself to do the things that
you want to do I don't care how good you
are to care how talented you are I don't
care how much you work on yourself there
are some times when things aren't going
to go right they just I'm not going to
go right there are times with anything
that can happen will happen Murphy's Law
will be knocking at your door why I
don't know why that's called life and
you have to deal with it sometimes your
life will be in a slump just like sports
some of the best shooters can't hit
baskets different times and games they
get in a slump do they sit on the
sidelines and say you know I just did
hit a basket today
no they continue to execute I suggest to
you that if you are facing a challenge
don't stop stay busy work your plan
continue to do those things that you
know that work for you after you have
evaluated yourself in the situation
continue to move stay busy stay busy
stay busy
after having 238 radiation seed implants
I was reading what nights and words by
dr. Howard Thurman who was a mentor to
dr. Martin Luther King jr. to Albert
Schweitzer to Mahatma Gandhi he wrote
deep is to hunger the voice of the
genuine the centering moment as I was
reflecting on his words
that the ideal situation for a man a
woman to die is that family members
praying with them as they cross over he
said but imagine if you will being on
your deathbed and standing around your
bed the ghost of the dreams the ideas
the abilities the talents given to you
by life with you for whatever reason you
never pursued those dreams you never
acted on those ideas you never use those
gifts you never use those talents and
that they are staring at you as you're
lying on your bed with large angry eyes
saying we came to you only you could
have given us life and now we must die
with you forever and the question is if
you die today what dreams what talents
what abilities what gifts what ideas
would die with you one Minister out of
the Hama said the Wellness place in the
planet it's not in the forest where the
soil on the ground it's not in South
Africa where there diamond mines he said
the wealthiest place in the planet
it's the cemetery there you see
potential never realized there you find
books never written there you find ideas
never acted on maybe that's why Henry
David Thoreau said Oh God to reach the
point of death only to realize that
you've never lived only to realize that
you've never scraped the surface of your
potential it's hard changing your life
it was hard when just over three years
ago in the Penobscot building in Detroit
Michigan where I was operating my
business and I fell on some hard times
and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment
and I said yes and I walked up to the
counter and he gave me an envelope and
he said would you mind reading it here
and I opened the envelope and the
envelope was from management that says
this is an office tower it's not a hotel
please do not sleep in your office and I
said excuse me sir I said I just worked
long hours and creating my business I'm
an entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor him and two
other dreamers up there look at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I can do it
there were times that I doubted myself I
said God why why is this happening to me
I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a Rob from anybody how did this
have to happen to me it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you for
those of you that have experienced some
hardships don't give up on your dream no
one could have convinced me by holding
on by continuing to push forward by
continuing to run toward my dream that
one day I would have my own talk show
it's a long shot ladies and gentlemen
from Liberty City an abandoned building
order floor never knowing my mother or
father it's a long shot being here with
you today in this dome in Atlanta it's a
long shot no college training labeled
educable mentally [ __ ] but I kept
running toward my dream
goes down
don't stop
don't stop running to watch your dream
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
you think Alice Brown if you're feeling
motivated after this video I feel like
it's hard not to but let me know what
you think let me know which cup was your
favorite leaving in the comments below
and I will join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon